so
um
so welcome everyone uh my name is
anthony elizabeth i'm the director of
the yale project on climate change
communication and uh thank you so much
for making the time to come join us
today um
we have got a very uh i think
interesting uh set of presentations and
panel discussions for you and we really
do encourage a lot of discussion with
you as well we will have a lunch
uh after the event as well so we hope
that there's an opportunity for some uh
chance to meet each other and talk about
these important issues
okay so what i'd like to do is just
quickly give you a few uh comments about
what this panel is and it really
represents the work of about six years
of active research in the united states
in china and in india
um
at the yale project of climate change
communication we've been studying
american public opinion for over a
decade
and very extensively since about 2008.
uh just about two years ago we were very
fortunate to find our good friends uh dr
jean bahwe and juan vincent
who were in the process of forming a
china center for climate change
communication and we found each other
and it's been a wonderful partnership
ever since it's been
such a great opportunity to become their
friends as well as to work with them
in china
and at the same time we started a
project looking at uh how indians were
responding to climate change as well and
dr jackman zachary worked very closely
with me uh over several years to do that
study as well
so what all of us are really trying to
understand are the answers to a few
basic questions
what do
mass publics in the united states china
and india understand and misunderstand
about the causes the consequences and
the potential solutions to climate
change how do they perceive the risks so
the likelihood and the severity of
different kinds of impacts
what kinds of climate and energy related
behaviors are they engaged in uh what
would they like to engage in and what
are the barriers that prevent them from
changing their behavior
and last but not least is their
political support for action
will they support the political leaders
that need to
be bold and take serious action to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions will
they support the policies that are
needed to both reduce emissions as well
as to start preparing for now the
inevitable impacts of climate change
and of course as scientists and we are
all scientists here we're interested in
answering the question why
what are the underlying psychological
cultural political reasons why some
people become very engaged with the
issue of climate change and demand
action and other people ignore or even
deny or dismiss
climate change as a serious concern
so
again here we're going to be
highlighting some of the results of our
work in these three countries
see the agenda uh we're going to cover a
bunch of ground um professor uh jung
will give a few introductory remarks and
i'll talk about what's happening in the
united states uh then we'll
look at china
then we'll do a few comparisons we
actually have a few questions that were
similarly asked in both countries and
they are starting to reveal some
interesting comparisons so we're just
starting that process
um then we'll look at what's happening
in india uh and then we'll have a panel
discussion about what are some of the
insights of this research for climate
communicators and educators going
forward
so with that i'd like to now turn it
over to my dear friend and colleague dr
john bowen
so
foreign
foreign
foreign
okay so thanks every again everyone uh
we're going to start with a look at
what's happening inside the united
states um
so there has been a series of major
shifts in climate change in the american
mind
uh as we like to title this project and
what we've been doing is studying again
how americans are responding this issue
over the past decade what i'm going to
do here is show you some of the results
from about the past five years worth of
research and it's going to illustrate
illustrate a couple major trends that i
think have had a major impact on the
political climate of climate change in
the united states and helps to explain
why the united states has been so
reluctant to take more aggressive action
on climate change up to this point
so again these are all nationally
representative surveys i'm happy to talk
about the underlying methodology with
anyone who wants to know but i'm not
going to bore you with those details
at the moment
but let's take a look at some of the
important findings so first of all
this is a basic question of do you
believe that global warming is happening
or not
okay and what we found is that there was
essentially a high water mark at the
high level was back in 2008 when about
71 percent of americans said yes they
believed that global warming was real
that then we saw a major drop
of about 14 percentage points from 2008
to 2010 and by the way this same exact
trend was found by every other single
survey research organization in the
united states that asked the same
question repeatedly over time
the same
very significant downward trend and this
you're going to see this trend
showing up in the number of these slides
but since then since that
low point is slowly crawled back up
until now when we are back at about 70
percent of the american public who again
believe that climate change is happening
so this pattern this v pattern of a
major decline followed by a recovery or
a rebound is a pattern we're going to
see again so this is do you believe
climate change is happening or not and
as you can see a substantial number of
americans still however believe that it
is not happening at all
likewise do you what do you believe is
the cause of climate change
under a little bit um
what we see here
is that
we had a high water mark or a top level
of about 57 percent of americans who
said that climate change is mostly
caused by human activities back in 2008
a 10-point drop to 2010 and then it has
slowly come back up until just last
september just a few months ago it is
now back up to 54
but you still have 30 of americans who
believe that if climate change is
happening it's caused by natural factors
not anything that humans have done not
that humans can do anything about
very important point
again a decline and this is the question
do most scientists believe that global
warming is happening now note this
question is not asking do scientists
think that climate change is human
caused this is not asking do people
think that climate change is a serious
problem this is just asking do
scientists agree that it's happening
about which there is notice even the
most adequate uh
skeptics or critics of climate science
do not dispute the climate is warming
and yet
even back at the high water mark back in
2008 only 47 less than half of americans
understood that
now it is back up to 44
and you still have 36 percent of
americans who believe there's a lot of
disagreement among scientists
that global warming exists and there's
even a small proportion of maybe about
five percent of americans who think that
scientists are actually agreed that it's
not
this is not by accident and i'll come
back to this point later in the talk but
this key belief right here that
scientists are still in disagreement
about the nature of the problem itself
is one of the major issues that still
needs to be resolved in the united
states
okay
again
are americans worried about climate
change well again
we kind of saw the highest levels of
this back in 2008 uh
when we had well over 50 percent of
americans saying that they were at least
somewhat too very worried about this
issue again a major drop to 2010 and
then slowly crawling back up until we're
just now at about uh what is that 58
americans who say that they're at least
somewhat worried about this issue
but no
importantly
even now
16
only 16 of americans say that they're
very worried about this issue and this
has been a very consistent finding over
many many years yes
a majority of americans do think it's
happening and they now do think that
it's human caused
but
they're not very worried about it so why
is that why aren't people worried about
this issue
well there's a range of reasons but one
of the most important reasons that we've
seen again and again and again is that
for many americans they think of climate
change
as a distant problem
just in time that the impacts won't be
felt for a generation or more
and distant in space that this is a
problem that's going to impact polar
bears or small island countries in the
south pacific not the united states
not my state
not my community not my friends and
family or the people of places that i
care about
so it's one of these issues that just
out there someday somewhere else it'll
be a serious problem but they don't see
how it's going to be relevant to their
own lives and thus it's not seen as a
very important problem and they don't
worry about it that much and how else
does that show up
it shows up in political will
public will and political will this
chart shows that this is data from the
pew research center from the spring of
2012 america's top priorities for the
president and congress and what you see
unsurprisingly
me and jobs are overwhelmingly the
number one priority and since 2007
these numbers 86 percent of americans 82
percent of americans say these should be
top priorities and those numbers have
grown dramatically not a big surprise
why that is of course 2008 is the exact
moment when
the whole world financial system
threatens collapse
where is global warming
right here
all the way at the bottom
only 25 percent of americans say
uh this should be one of the top
priorities for the
president in congress and since 2007
that has dropped 13 percentage points
climate change has always been at the
bottom of this list
how about the environment the
environment does a little better as a
broader category 43 percent of americans
say that should be a priority but that
too dropped 14 percentage points since
2007. how about energy
here's energy
about half of americans say that should
be a top priority but that too dropped
five percentage points since 2007. okay
so this
fact that okay so a majority of
americans do
believe that climate change is happening
in human cause and then
some actions should be taken but it's
not seen as one of the top tier issues
that people are going to vote on or that
their elected officials should act on
okay so why did we see those declines
since 2007 2008 well we like to say this
is a perfect storm is where a whole
bunch of things all happened at once
that really drove these numbers there
wasn't any one thing but one of course
is the economy and unemployment again
2007 2008 is when the real estate bubble
broke and uh popped in the united states
the economy and the financial financial
system was in crisis and unemployment
surged up over 10 in the united states
and it became of course one of the top
uh issues that led to barack obama being
elected in the fall of 2008.
but what's also not fully recognized is
that there was a major decline in media
coverage in this issue okay now my
colleagues max boycott has been tracking
newspaper coverage in the united states
newspaper coverage and i'm just talking
quantity of articles
not quality not whether you know how
they're describing it or what the
content of the stories or anything just
number of articles that mention global
warming or climate change has dropped
since 2007 by about two-thirds
and my colleague
bob rule has been studying uh knightly
network news coverage so the major
networks like cbs abc nbc nightly news
that coverage has dropped by about 90
percent
now this is an issue climate change that
our window here we can all look out the
window and there's co2 pouring out of
the smokestacks out of the tailpipes and
out of the buildings
in fact there's co2
pouring out of all of us right now in
this room but you can't see it because
it's invisible
and likewise you can't see the impacts
unless you've been trained and know
where to look
so the only way the vast majority of
americans know about this issue i mean
look they don't know climate scientists
they don't read scientific journal
reports the only way they know about
this is through media coverage and when
the media does not report this issue it
is literally out of sight and out of
mind
it doesn't mean they've completely
forgotten the idea of climate change but
it's just not sailing it's not they're
not being reminded of it and this is why
the media plays such an important role
in shaping public consciousness
we also have some unusually cold weather
events in the united states in these
years the united uh media does to
sensationalize things so they dug one of
these snowpocalypse and the other one's
snowmageddon uh big snowstorms and we
know that for those people who don't
really know much about the issue and
haven't really taken a firm position on
it they will draw on personal experience
or recent experience to make up their
mind about global warming so when they
saw a massive snowstorm someone said
well gosh that doesn't seem like global
warming
even though that's of course completely
consistent with climate change but
that's a harder scientific understanding
that many people lack
we also have to recognize that there's
been a pretty effective denial industry
which has been very well documented uh a
whole set of companies as well as
individual
think tanks that have very strong
conservative free market ideology have
been real leaders and actually quite
effective communicators at raising
public doubts about this issue even
about whether it's happening or human
caused or a serious problem
uh and of course back in 2009 we had the
climate gate so-called scandal
and our own research has shown that that
uh that scandal in fact did have a
significant impact on public opinion
about 12 percent of americans said they
became less convinced that climate
change is real
and more importantly lost trust in
climate scientists as messengers
but importantly that effect was not
spread across the entire country was
highly concentrated among conservative
republicans who tend to watch fox news
in rush limbaugh and when we went and
looked at the media coverage it turns
out that you know the new york times and
the cbse news recovery a couple times
but on fox news and russia talked about
it again and again and again and again
and again and again and again and always
with a very um sinister interpretation
we also have to recognize there's been
increasing political polarization on
this issue in the united states where we
have democrats and republicans actually
using climate change to attack each
other okay and i think that's a dynamic
that we don't see in many other
countries around the world
okay but then why have we seen the
rebound in the past couple years what's
been happening well we're still trying
to answer that question but one of the
things we know is that first of all the
economy and unemployment are improving
people are feeling a little more
confident about it and they're beginning
to pay more attention to other issues
but
we've also seen a start
increase of media coverage nowhere back
to the level we saw in 2007 but it's
definitely starting to pick up again and
one of the reasons for that is that the
united states has just endured two years
of devastating record uh breaking uh
extreme weather events
one after another after another after
another and what we've been documenting
in our work is that americans are paying
attention to that they're beginning to
connect the dots themselves between
climate change and these extreme weather
events
so we've asked
do you think that global warming is
affecting weather in the united states
and we find that a strong majority of
americans do think so
likewise we find that majorities agree
that climate change has made a whole
series of very specific extreme other
events that the united states has
experienced recently worse so the record
high summer temperatures i mean
record-setting temperatures across much
of the united states last summer uh
large majorities say yeah they think
climate change had something to do with
that
the drought in the midwest and the great
plains the unusually warm winter we had
in 2011 2012. for those of you that have
ever been to chicago illinois it was in
the about 85 degrees i believe in
january which is not what it's supposed
to be it's supposed to be probably more
like 20 degrees uh in january in chicago
um we had record forest fires in the
american west and a very unusual uh
what's called the racial storm that blew
through the east coast okay a whole
series of one after another after
another after another extreme weather
events and again americans are starting
to think that they might be connected to
something
okay
and
now let's turn to policy support well
one of the actually pieces of good news
is though on climate change may not be
one of the top tier priorities for
americans they have long been consistent
supporters of national action on climate
energy okay
so these numbers are actually not
unusual we've seen these for a long time
there's been strong majority support
bipartisan support for democrats and
republicans for funding more research
into renewable energy sources like wind
and solar very strong social consensus
on that providing tax rebates for people
who purchase energy efficient vehicles
or solar panels regulating carbon
dioxide is a pollutant which
unfortunately is now probably the main
policy that the obama administration is
going to have to pursue is having the
epa try to regulate co2
buy power plants
interestingly in the context of our
negotiations here eliminating all
subsidies for the fossil fuel industry
you have a majority of americans who
actually support that
the fossil fuel industry is not
particularly loved in the united states
people don't have positive feelings
about
the oil industry or oil big oil
companies as an example and i think you
see some of that in here and then very
interestingly you do not have a majority
supporting something like a carbon tax
but we're beginning to see that
depending on what's done with the money
from the carbon tax you can actually get
a majority of people in the united
states to support it
so if that money was used for example uh
was returned right back to taxpayers
they tend to support that
it was used to
spur investments in clean energy
and green jobs they definitely support
that
so the carbon tax who knows it's hard to
believe that the united states could
ever even think about passing an attack
but as we see right now they're talking
about raising revenues as part of the
so-called fiscal cliff discussions
also very interesting and this has been
a consistent finding over many years is
that when we ask americans should the
united states reduce its uh
that the u.s should reduce the
greenhouse gas emissions
a majority of them say we should do so
regardless of what other countries do
only two percent say that we should only
do that if other industrialized
countries do only seven percent of
americans say we need to wait until both
other industrialized and developing
countries
and only five percent just say no not
reduce our emissions at all okay so this
actually goes quite contradictory to
this stated policy position of the
united states for many years now that we
will not act until
all the developing countries sign up as
well
so the public isn't actually there now
that doesn't mean the public is
demanding that the negotiators pass the
treaty but this is their
their basic start
and more specifically we've been asking
for a number of years how much would you
support or oppose signing an
international treaty that requires the
united states to cut its emissions and
greenhouse of carbon dioxide 90 by the
year 2050
and all through these years we've seen
about two-thirds of americans say yes
okay they would support the united
states signing a treaty like that do
americans really understand what signing
a treaty and cutting 90 emissions would
entail no of course not
but it does show that they are at least
in principle quite supportive of
international action to deal with this
collective threat
okay so to summarize
uh as we've seen public understanding of
climate change declined from 2008 to
2011 but we're starting to see a real
rebound
it remains to be seen whether that will
stay or continue
public understanding concern about
climate change is getting better as the
economy is improving and then as extreme
as they're experiencing one extreme
weather event another after another
which does this one thing it takes what
was a global distant problem
and it brings it home
and it says it's now
that's a really important piece of
communication and we'll come back to
that later
again we have continued majority support
for a variety of policies as well as an
international treaty but it's not a top
priority relative to other issues
and that's in large part because again
it's still this is relatively distant
threat and thus there's a lack of public
and political will and as a result of
this relatively low priority
most american politicians don't feel
that they have to act
that they will be voted out of office if
they don't act or that they need to be a
leader on this issue in order to achieve
the level of higher office
so with that i will now turn it over to
juan goodman we'll talk about our
results from china
okay thanks tony's a comprehensive
introduction
as tony sanchez uh introduced uh
university has conducted this kind of
research for more than five years
but for china's center for climate
change communication it's our first time
to conduct this kind of survey with
support from different areas
especially from your university
in fact it's not only in china but also
in developing countries
the this is the first
survey
on climate change communication and the
first study in this area
okay
let's move on to the key fundings of the
survey
china center for climate change
communication conducted a national
television survey in this july and
august and the user combined jojo and
the urban sample which included four
thousand and one hundred and sixty nine
example
this study
most focused on the current state of
public climate change awareness beliefs
attitudes policy support and behaviors
let's have a look at this this funding
it's about knowing so it's obviously
only seven percent of the chinese never
heard of climate change so it means
around 93 percent they know
at least a little about climate change
so it's about knowing and then about
happening
uh very similar data
also uh about nine per uh
93 percent
chinese they said they know
they think climate change is happening
so
um
i think it's because in china now uh
climate change is a very
hot
term
because not only the government but also
the scientists and also the media ngos
they're all talking about climate change
so if you have a chance to visit china
if you can talk about something about
climate change i'm sure
no one will see you out so remember this
and next funding is about
the reason about climate change
uh compared to the former two uh data
here we can see there there's not uh
there's no
much consensus on the reason of climate
change only about half the
climate changes caused by
human activities
so about to worry
and only eight percent
they said
they are not at all worried about
climate change
so it means
majority chinese they think climate
change is uh they are worried about
climate change and because they are
varied so it means people have
much interest to know more about climate
change and it will provide more space
for government media and ngo to
contribute to more in this area
so personally experience
60 percent chinese think
they have personally experienced climate
change
especially related to the china context
you know in china most of chinese are in
rural areas so uh and the climate change
what's the who is the witness of climate
change of course the people in the
rural area especially the poorest people
and this one is about
uh
one uh when do you think climate change
will start to harm people in china
and you can see
it doesn't work okay
um 69
people they say they are being pumped
now
so it's related to the
last data and this one how much do you
think about climate change will um
say here
the same number uh 69
chinese think the
the
the agree that climate change will harm
future generations a great deal
this charm is very interesting
because you know uh there are different
nominees about uh caused by climate
change uh some we call it extreme
weather so drought is a very typical
national
disaster in china so not only the north
of china but also the south of china
people have this kind of a
disaster so we just use this this
disaster to say the
vulnerability
and among all this
uh uh
one two three four five this this five
points uh we can see the the last one
the firings and the foot shortage uh is
the
not so many people think this has
happened it will it will be caused by
the joints because we can see
the march increase and the march uh
decrease the famine and the food
shortages are
they are
they are lower or much higher than the
average value it means they're extremely
extreme value is
we can we can see we can find it from
the extreme value
so i think it's because in china
more and more media and the government
began to care about climate change but
there are focus on what is climate
change and yes it's happening in china
now but with now we did some basic
research on the relationship between
food issues
food shortage and climate change
this one is about
some
statement and
89
chinese they are they totally agree the
government should pay greater attention
to climate change issue and here you can
see only
46 percent they agreed that as a
personal behavior change will changes
will influence the uh the serving of
climate change issues it's very
interesting here because
it will it can reflect
the
chinese thinking habit you know china
is a big government and small
small society
so
people chinese usually to rely on the
gut but not their own self so when they
met some with the base number challenge
with some problem if you're first of all
think of sick of yes i need to uh go to
the government to find some help so this
is why here the government can get them
more supported
but this is the problem you know no one
can
address the climate change with their
own effort so
not only the government but also the
whole society need to pay more attention
to climate change and this is the k
point we should be uh pay a pay a more a
bit more attention to in china and not
only for the government but also for the
uh for the uh some research research
institute that
to
call on more people more general people
general public to
fight against somebody change
okay this one
is also
many
majority people think that the
government should play the most
important actor in addressing climate
change and here the public is uh not so
you know not so low the data here um
but the media and the corporation and
the ngo is very
very low so it's another uh
reality in china
it's very uh different from uh us
as uh why discussed this with tony he
told me that the u.s corporation
yeah the public think corporation should
play the most important role all the
important role
to address the climate change but in
china
because
china is partly market oriented society
so it means
the government um
still
trying to manage the
corporation operation so
if the government say yes we should do
then the corporation will follow up so
it leads to the public they used to
think yes it's not the corporation
corporation who can decide or who can
play the most important role and related
to ngo
and
in china
uh i think most of you may remember the
huge disaster in china huge earthquake
in 2008
the sioux trans earthquake and it's that
moment
that more chinese begin to realize ngos
yeah there's some organization of course
ngo environmental
development and they are doing some work
in china and they began to have this
kind of awareness
so it's just
here now so far it's just a
full four years for five years so it's
still a long term for chinese public to
understand and to
to know more about ntos country
contribution
this one's about
yeah this is the last data this was
about a policy support
from the color you can see the blue
color is the support and that means the
support and the red colors means
opposed
so
obviously
the chinese chinese people this supports
policy very well
so
actually in this in recent years
especially after 2009 chinese government
have made many uh policies to address
climate change and
simply they get a very well
support here's a something
93 percent of chinese climate change
happening and 55 percent think that
climate change is caused by human
activities
78 percent see they are worried about
climate change at different levels 60
percent see they have personally
experienced the effect of climate change
and 69 percent think that people in
china are already being harmed by
climate change 68 percent then
government should play the most
important role in regarding to climate
change
so uh in brief although most of people
say that copenhagen is a failure but we
can say here you know in china it's just
after copenhagen ironically
that the government began to pay more
and more attention to climate change
issue so here you can see
uh more and more people begin to realize
that climate change is happening climate
change is there and we are being harmed
by economic change but
regarding to the reason to look married
to the
uh who can play the role in this in this
field they still have some confusion so
we still have a government media ngo and
all the
institutions we can do a lot in this
area
that's my sharing thank you
uh
jack jack there we go thank you okay
well thank you very much uh
we'll do one other uh comparison because
we've just seen the results from the
united states and from china and like i
mentioned before there are a few
questions that we asked in the same way
in both countries and so we thought
just for interest we would put we would
show you four of those uh results
that compare the two different countries
side by side and the first one that you
see here do you think that global
warming or climate change and i should
say global warming is the term that's
used in the united states and climate
change was the term that's used in china
and there are always translation issues
so that you know certainly will play an
important role in some of this as well
but nonetheless
do you think uh global warming or
climate change is caused mostly by human
activities by natural changes in the
environment some other cause or none of
these because it's not happening and
interestingly the united states and
china are almost identical when it comes
to believe that human activities are to
cause it's a majority but just a slight
majority in both countries but then we
come to is it natural
uh is it just the result of natural
changes and we find that interestingly
about 38
of chinese believe that it's natural
whereas
relatively fewer in the united states 30
percent say that it is
we'll come back to that in a moment
uh also
have you personally experienced the
effects of global warming or climate
change here we see a more a sharper
difference between the two countries 60
percent of chinese believe that they
have already experienced the impacts in
some way or another only 38
say that in the united states
when do you think the global warming
climate change will start to harm people
in your own country
okay and again here we're seeing a very
stark difference only 36 of americans
say that they are being harmed right now
by climate change again that sense that
is distant like i was talking about
before
by contrast nearly 7 out of 10 chinese
believe that they are being armed right
now
and that sense of more imminent threat
plays out when we ask them the simple
question of how worried are you about
this issue and we find that
by and large the chinese say that
they're both more very worried and
somewhat worried about this issue than
in the united states
so what might explain some of these
contrasting results well um i have a few
thoughts we're still working i mean this
is a brand new data actually from china
we just received and started doing this
now since a couple weeks ago but we have
at least got a few speculations that
we'll share with you now and we'd be
happy to talk more about this when we
get to the q a
um back to the issue of
uh is it happening or not uh well
actually i'll come back to that because
we didn't show that but 93 again of
chinese believe that climate change is
happening only 70 percent of americans
believe that it's happening um i was in
that some of these differences are
because of things like what i talked
about before that you have a very active
denial movement in the united states
of scientists of powerful interests of
news organizations that work very
closely together to push out a very
strong communication
message and strategy to raise doubts
about the reality of climate change and
i think again they've been reasonably
successful in that
um
also you know the u.s media has played
an important role in this issue in that
they've given um we have huge insurance
of schemes in position to help people
the federal government will immediately
step in and spend
dozens and billions of dollars to help
people rebuild their lives
that's certainly not the case in many
other countries around the world and
it's not
fully the case yet in china either
and the flip side of that of course is
that many chinese are still living at or
below the poverty line
and then just this last point again back
to the
questioning the reality of climate
change and the seriousness of it is that
climate change has become politicized in
the united states
where democrats and republicans use this
issue to attack each other to try to
score political points
you know in this past presidential
election we had a very stark uh example
of that where every single uh republican
running for the presidency with the
exception of jon huntsman who didn't
last very long um
either questioned the reality of climate
change or flat out said it was a hoax
okay
so when one of the two major political
parties that represents roughly half the
electorate in in the country is willing
to say as leaders that this is a hoax
it shows you what a
the kind of
political gridlock and even dysfunction
that the united states is currently
enduring with this issue and so the
united states has a major political
problem that we still need to work
through uh in order to get to the bigger
issues like what people are talking
about here
at doha
do you have other comments you'd like to
say about the comparison between the two
countries i think you have given us a
very convicted
complicated analysis so i'd like to
leave more time to the q a section and
we'll have please thank you okay
so i think what we'll do is we'll uh and
then um because we got started a little
late with uh the presentations about
india's results and then we can have an
open discussion about all three
countries so johnny
well i know we're all getting hungry so
i'll try to keep my presentation short
so india is one of the most vulnerable
countries to climate change
however currently we almost know nothing
if indians are aware of climate change
understand the causes consequences or
potential solutions to mitigate an
adaptive climate change impacts
so to assess indians climate change
awareness beliefs their risk perceptions
behavior and policy support as well as
they perceive vulnerability and
resilience to climate and climate change
impacts particularly on water related
issues uh in project and climate change
communication along with globe scan and
sea water conducted a national sample
survey in november december 2011.
i'm going to spend some time unlike tony
in trying to talk about the sampling
plan
so what we did was uh the primary
sampling unit for this climate change
and then buying survey was the
parliamentary constituency unit in 21
out of the 35 indian states and union
territories and at least one
assembly constituency which is a local
body state level local political unit
was randomly selected using a random
number generator uh from each of such
randomly selected assembly consequences
we select we again randomly selected one
polling station
and following the electorate list
provided
the first respondent was randomly
selected followed by every 10th
respondent on the list if the respondent
was absent or refused to participate in
a survey uh
the next respondent was uh you know
was asked to participate in the
interview followed by the next 10th best
one and so on so following uh this
stratified random sampling plan we
covered 134 urban semi-urban and rural
communities in 21 or of 35 indian states
and union territories
representing 98 percent of the indian
population
overall total of
4031 respondents completed face-to-face
interviews which lasted about 40 minutes
resulting in a response rate of 40
percent and a margin of error 1.54
the final the data set was weighted to
match the actual age
gender
religious and regional distribution of
the target population moreover the
questionnaire was translated into 12
major indian languages including hindi
gujarati marathi telugu and others
because india is such a linguistically
diverse country
however the
presentation here is from the complete
sample which has a strong urban bias
where three by four of the respondents
come from the large medium or the small
cities
now the first question refers to how
much do they know about global warming
when we add this to the respondents we
find that 41
of the respondents say that they either
never have heard of it or they don't
know the global warming only a minority
seven percent say that they know a lot
about it what this shows is that a
majority of indians are not aware of
climate change and may lack climate
change as a conceptual framework to make
sense of the local
so to make sense of the observed changes
in their local area and to make
decisions about the future
because we know that indians are largely
unaware of climate change from other
issues from other surveys as well
we followed the awareness question with
a brief description of what global
warming means
we said global warming refers to the
idea that the world's average
temperature has been increasing over the
past 150 years
maybe increasing more in the future and
that the world's climatic and weather
patterns may change as a result
what do you think
do you think global warming is happening
when we provided just two-line
definition of what global warming means
we find that two out of three
respondents said yes
it is happening
while most of the indians may not be
aware of climate change and many have
never heard of the term global warming
or climate change but we find that when
we provide a short description of what
it means
it seems to resonate with the lived
experience
when asked if global warming is
primarily caused by human activities or
as a result of natural changes in the
environment we find that 6 out of 10
respondents say that it's mostly caused
by human activities
another 31 percent say that is mostly
caused by natural changes in the
environment and only a minority
two percent say that it's not happening
at all
when asked uh how worried are they about
global warming only 20
said that they are very worried about
global warming
an additional 41 percent are the highest
single response and that they are
somewhat worried about global warming
we find that a majority of our
respondents perceive high vulnerability
to climate change impacts including they
feel they're personally vulnerable their
family is vulnerable people in their
community and people in india are
vulnerable to the impact of climate
change
but they feel that the risks are far
greater for future generations of people
and for plants and animal species
when asked when do you think the global
warming will start to harm people in
india we find that 21 percent say they
are being harmed right now
another 22 percent say that they are
being harmed they will be harmed in 10
years but a majority 57 percent say that
the
the harmful impacts of global warming or
at least a generation away there's a 25
years or 50 years yes
as six percent say never so
uh the majority that 57 percent feel
that the impacts or at least the harmful
impacts of global warming are at least a
generation away
apart from understanding climate change
awareness beliefs and risk perceptions
uh the climate change in indian mind
survey was also interested to understand
perceived vulnerability to climate
change impacts and when we ask
if a one year long severe drought
happened in your local area how big an
impact would it have on each of the
following and we find that more than 50
of our respondents feel that their water
supply their food supply their health
and income are highly vulnerable to the
impact of a severe
extreme weather event such as severe
drought and let me remind you that
extreme weather events such as severe
droughts and floods made increasing
frequency and intensity due to climate
change
just as important as vulnerability is
resilience meaning how long would it
would a household for a community day to
recover from an extreme weather event
and we find that over 50 percent of more
than 60 percent of our respondents said
that they would take several months
to several years
to recover from an impact of an extreme
weather event such as severe drought or
severe flood in other words
uh indians more generally perceive low
resilience to the impacts of extreme
weather events again which might
increase in frequency and intensity due
to climate change
when asked how big of an effort should
india make to reduce global warming and
we find that 77 percent of our
respondents said that
77 our respondents support a national
plan to reduce global warming including
over a third of the respondents
supporting a large-scale effort even if
it has large economic costs
although the question is kind of
abstract because what's the difference
between a large economic cost and a
small economic cost but the answers do
indicate an overall willingness
to act on global warming even if it has
some economic costs
when asked ventured india reduced
emission we find that the single highest
response 38 percent say that india
should reduce its own emissions
immediately without waiting for other
countries that
about what about four or ten respondents
say that india should act unilaterally
without waiting for other countries
and reduce its emissions
however
44 of our respondents say that either
that india should not reduce its
emissions under any circumstances or
should do so only when other countries
act
finally we ask them about a variety of
policy support measures that the
government of india has proposed as part
of his national action plan and we find
that a majority of our respondents
support these policies including saving
water
energy
and forests
reducing the number of coal-fired power
plants
increasing investment in renewable
energy sources
and increasing water local uh increasing
water access by encouraging local
communities to build check dams
the highest policy that they supported
however is a national program to teach
all indians about global warming where
we find 70
of our respondents support that plan
in other words it seems that indians
want to know more about global warming
which is again reflected the first
question which where we saw that 41 of
the respondents either said they have
never heard but don't know about climate
change
just to summarize we find that only
seven percent of indians know a lot
about global warming
but when we provide just a two-line
definition of what it means
we find a complete reversal where we
find a two out of three respondents
agree that global warming is happening
moreover 56 percent or 6 out of 10
respondents think that global warming is
mostly human cause
only 20 percent of indians are feeling
are feel very worried about climate
change and most of them perceive it to
be distant in time
that is going to happen next generation
and impacting other species such as
animal and plants
a large majority of indians say that
their household is vulnerable to extreme
weather events and they also say that
they might take several months several
years to recover from an extreme weather
event in the local area
and finally majority of our respondents
said that to support national action to
reduce emissions
even if these policies increase consumer
costs
thank you so much
okay so uh what we're going to do now
then is just uh we'll each take just a
couple minutes to say a few words about
what we think these uh results
what are some of the insights that we're
learning from these studies and what
they might mean for climate
communication in each of our respective
countries um so i'm gonna go first and
then we'll hear a little bit from china
and then a little bit from india and
then we really it's all about opening it
up and let's have a conversation from
all of you
okay so one of the things that we've
discovered in the united states as well
in this research is that uh there are
three things that of course are so
crucial to any effective communications
your audience
your message
and your messenger
and then audiences it's one of the first
rules of affected communication is you
must know who your audience is who are
they where do you find them what do they
understand what do they think they
understand what are their values where
do they get their news and information
from whom do they trust you need to know
all of that otherwise it's like playing
darts in a crowded room with the lights
off
you might hit the target sometimes but
most often you're going to miss
and sometimes you're going to cause
collateral damage you're going to hit an
innocent bystander and
cause a backlash
communication is the same thing you need
to know who you're trying to reach and
how to reach them and in the united
states we've realized that the american
public doesn't speak with a single voice
there's in fact many publics within the
united states and when it comes to the
issue of climate change we've identified
six distinct americans that each respond
to this issue in very different ways
i won't talk about them much here but
this kind of insight is now being used
by organizations
all over the united states from the
federal government state government
local government
corporations are using this
educators are using this zoos aquariums
and museums are using this framework to
try to understand who are they trying to
engage with which of these audiences um
are in their constituency or in their
market
so they range from the alarm just very
quickly
who are firmly convinced climate change
is happening human cause is an urgent
threat all the way down to the
dismissive who are convinced that it's
not happening not human caused and in
fact many believe it's a hoax and then
in between our different types of views
but another key thing that we've learned
is that the message really matters as i
said before most americans in fact
99.99999 percent of americans do not
know a climate scientist personally they
do not read scientific journals they
have never even heard of the ipcc report
okay we actually ask people have you
ever heard of the ipcc
okay i won't even take the time to ask
you to guess is 14 of americans have
ever heard of the ipcc 14
after decades of news uh reports and so
on about the ipcc and the thing that we
all assume everybody knows about no we
live within a very green
climate change bubble okay everyone in
this room is
very different than the vast majority of
the planet
most people have never heard of the ipc
so
we have to recognize that for most
people yes you
you always want to make as much
information available and transparently
available for people as possible and you
want to make it and explain it in ways
that people can understand absolutely
for anyone who's interested to learn
more but at the same time we have to
recognize that most people are not going
to go get
a college degree in climatology they're
not going to study the ipcc reports
they're not going to go read those
journal articles or anything so the
challenge for the communication
community is really this
if you have maybe five ideas and i'm
making that number up maybe it's three
maybe it's four maybe it's seven but
it's some small number of ideas that
they have mental space for you to to get
into their head
what five ideas should they know about
climate change that will allow them to
make good decisions going forward okay
now this is an open question and it's an
open question in every society every
country may be different but in the
united states right now our best uh
estimate uh as of now but we're still
doing work is that it basically boils
down to this
ten words
it's real
it's us
that's causing it
it's gonna be bad especially for human
beings not just polar bears
that scientists are in agreement about
this fact
and there's hope that there are
solutions right ready at hand to take
action
and that can be done in ways that
actually will help the economy and grow
jobs and so on
most people don't understand all five
days and moreover what we've learned is
that that one idea that the experts
agree is what we call a gateway belief
because it turns out that your correct
understanding of this shapes everything
else i mean again
most people don't know anything about
climate change
just like most people don't know
anything about nanotechnology
or biotechnology or genetically modified
food or sars or any of the risks that
the world faces today in fact i dare say
most of us aren't experts in all of
those topics i just raised and in that
situation you want to know well what do
the people who are expert in this think
what do the experts think
and if your perception is that the
experts themselves don't agree about
whether it's even happening then why
would you take it that risk seriously
all of us are in that same situation and
most of the public is as well and so
what we find is that when people
correctly understand that the experts
agree that climate change is happening
and human caused they become much more
likely themselves to say it's happening
human cause is going to be bad for
people and that is solvable and in turn
they then support climate policy and
more actions by everyone in society
including themselves
so we think this is one of the most
important messages that we need to
communicate in the united states
last point is about bringing it back
home making it real for people so it's
not some abstract distant threat to
people and places far away and what we
have begun is a major national project
working with the nation's weather
pastors tv and radio broadcast
meteorologists who are who actively have
the eyes and ears of the vast majority
of the american public climate
scientists
could be much better communicators many
of them are not great communicators but
they could be much better but in the end
they don't scale
they give a talk to 100 people here and
100 people there and the occasional
reporter but they have day jobs
you know they're supposed to do their
science and it just doesn't reach
hundreds of millions of people
weathercasters however are one of the
most important
players in american media because they
reach hundreds of millions of americans
every day three to four times a day and
they're highly trusted and
people watch them
and so what we're beginning to see with
for instance the extreme weather events
is that they have the ability to
educate americans about this issue and
so they're in some ways ideal messengers
uh to reach americans uh about climate
change
okay i'll leave it there
you have some thoughts yeah thank you
so in china i think
at the very beginning why we
conducted this program is because
in copenhagen we found
china really like
played a
passive role in the negotiation because
the government is not i was not very
familiar with the rules in this
negotiation for example
in the
second week when
there is a many uh scandal to a china
mountain
so the government feels very
nervous and don't know how to
communicate with the with the world so
at that moment we think yes we need to
do something to uh
help the government to open dialogue
with us with a civil society with the
world to tell them how to do it so this
is the very beginning why as a very
beginning way why we have this program
but uh
uh
time by time we think yeah
as we observed uh now in the
international negotiation
platform china began to play more and
more uh open
actor and they they have a really very
regular meeting with media with ngo
although there's still some you know
place to improve but at least they are
trying to
try their best so
we are thinking how can we do then at
the moment we think yeah uh
tony gave us
a very
vital suggestion that we need to do
something
nationally internally so
we begin to focus on how to you know uh
how to persuade people to believe
climate change uh
you know in china also uh there are not
so many people uh
maybe when they when they answer our
questionnaire about
you uh do you believe
climate change you will say yes but um
they're uh when we talk about climate
change or especially in the field when
we talk about climate change not so many
colleagues i think climate change really
happened
partly of course because uh the
scientists
didn't give us a very
strong voice
is happening but
from
our perspective we think because climate
change is related to environment issue
to a development issue
but both these two issues are related to
the sustainable development of human
beings so this is the first point the
second point is in china we really found
there are so many people around you know
around
900 million people are in a living
jewelry area and they are really in fact
affected by climate change so we have we
have
experienced so many stories and we have
talked with them and we know what
happened in their life so we think
personally we think yes
not only from the general meaning and
from the personal uh perspective
addressing climate change is very
important
and we should let more people know this
and the principle is no regret
and the second one is
um climate change have a very uh
comprehensive meaning
for example in the negotiation area not
only
the mitigation but also adaptation to
perspective and but most of people in
china they only know yeah when they talk
about climate change yes it's an
environmental issue and it's about the
low carbon is about the mitigation but
not so many people know
there are so many our brothers our
sisters in rural areas have been
impacted by climate change so this is
why we think it's very important we also
do climate change communication in china
to let them know yeah climate change is
not only related to the varying
opposite
in the far far away area and
but also in our family just in china so
it's uh this is uh
another uh
point and uh
regarding this point uh china center for
climate change have conducted many side
events examiner and
we also uh
released a new campaign in china it's a
public education campaign we try to call
more call on more people to go to the
rural area go to uh community go to the
uh corporation and the university to
teach more people to let more people
know what is climate change and what
climate change impacts diverse impact
and the
uh
the other the third third point is about
linear use
we can see very obviously uh chinese
media when reporting chinese their
experience are not so
harmful compared to the international
colleagues so
this is also what we can do
from a climate change communication
perspective to help them
and give them more chances to know about
uh to know how to report climate change
and how to you know play a much more
useful role
in this communication process and the
last but not least one is about policy
makers uh chinese government uh the now
people want bring more and more
attention to climate change not only
from the international level but also
national so
we think
how to how to make a useful
and
very efficient
policy we need to know the public
opinion
so the civil society in china need to
grow up as soon as possible
and what way
uh
one of the reasons why we conducted this
program is we want to help the civil
society to grow up and also you know
to
we could we can help the media help the
ngo and to learn to know to hear the
voice from the from the rural areas of
the general public and thus they can we
can transfer this voice to the
government and that's when the
government makes a policy we can think
about yes
which policy is much better to the to
the people in china and we can see
china
china's policies and actions for
addressing climate change just before
doha and they concluded uh all their uh
policies in china and they also
mentioned this time is their first time
to highlight what ngo's contribution and
they also introduce
china center
for climate change communications survey
in china as well and it means they
really begin to think about what's
chinese what general chinese is thinking
and i think it's a very vital and it's a
milestone for china thank you
okay jt you have some thoughts about uh
india quickly uh thank you tony
and i'm just going to rephrase what tony
said and what i learned from uh in way
back in center for climate change
communication in us
and this is the
addictive for communication
simple clear messages repeated often by
a variety of trusted sources
that is going to get as public involved
to support policy and to change their
behaviors let me say that again simple
clear messages repeated often by a
variety of trusted sources
now uh with reference to the climate
change indian data we find that only
seven percent say they know a lot about
it but when we provide a just two-line
definition
we see a complete turnaround we see 72
percent of our respondents saying that
yes it is happening and that's the
biggest communication lesson that we got
of this climate change in mind survey
that they want to connect the dots
between what they're
experiencing locally and they want to
know what's happening in the global
scale so that they can take better
decisions
at the local scale
so let me divide one of the
communication dictum into three parts
what kind of information they want
who do they want to hear it from and
what kind of policies that they want to
support so what kind of information they
want to hear uh it's i think they want
to hear more about the localized impacts
about climate change how their community
uh you know there the place that they
are living is going to get affected by
extreme weather events or the impacts of
other climate change climate change
impacts uh specifically how is that
personally going to affect my health
how is it going to affect my income
those are the kind of information that
they have they want to hear about it
who do they want to hear it from and
this is another thing that we asked in
the survey and you can find a complete
report in the reception area that the
indians trust scientists more often most
uh indians were scientists most among
the different social information the
next being your family and friends and
the environmental organizations so and
then it's a media organization and as
some of you might know that indian media
coverage actually has it has been very
simple died the
media account media covers about climate
change only during such events such as
cop 18 and then rest of the year there's
hardly any coverage so we want india in
media to cover more uh and more
consistently and more in depth and
perhaps cover issues that the local
people affect the local communities the
kind of information that they can use
uh finally what kind of policies that
they want to support is kind of an
important thing and we found that a
majority of indians support a variety of
policies even if they have to pay up a
little more
to mitigate and adapt to climate change
so
we should try getting more public
support to push the government
to act on climate change and as well as
the government should aggressively
implement more communication programs in
india apart from just
you know talking high in the
international
conferences thank you jt so now we
finally get to open it up and have a
discussion among all of us uh listen can
i um
jesse
bessie
messi
okay so does this work for you guys
so
let's start right here in the front
and if you could please introduce
yourself
i'm vanessa cassano from the carbon
disclosure project
and i wanted to thank the speakers for
their very insightful work it's been
really a fascinating
morning so my question really i suppose
it's directed to tony is
you talked about the sources
of information that influenced public
opinion and you pointed to the media
and i just wanted to ask if the research
considered the role of corporations
and specifically
the
the corporate positions public positions
and the mismatch between the
lobbying work that they do and their
government engagement and their public
information so that's my question okay
so the question is basically what's the
role of corporations in this mix as well
as public views of corporations
yeah and the inconsistencies
between
what corporations are telling
governments what corporations telling
the public and what that impact
is on public opinion sure
okay um
this is a big uh big topic
i think one of the most important things
to recognize is that corporations are
not homogeneous
there are many many many different kinds
of corporations and they have many
different positions on this issue
as we know there are many corporations
that have very publicly said we believe
climate change is real we think climate
change is human caused we think that
climate change is a serious risk it's a
serious risk to our bottom line as a
direct
uh
risk it's potentially a liability risk
to us
as well as uh it's also a potentially
enormous
market opportunity because somebody is
going to make the trillions of dollars
in the clean energy economy so who is
that going to be is that going to be my
company or is that going to be somebody
else's company or some other country so
i think first of all corporations
just like americans don't have a single
voice corporations don't have a single
voice either and we need to give a lot
of credit to those that are engaging the
issue
that said there have been a set of
companies that have had seen it in their
own self-interest to fight this issue
for many years
though that has changed in about the
past 10 to 15 years in the united states
there used to be an organization called
the global climate
uh in the united states made up
primarily of manufacturers fossil fuel
companies and so on that were united in
funding lots of other groups to say that
climate change isn't happening and
funding scientists to go and try to
provide a lot of misinformation and so
on that organization doesn't exist
anymore that organization completely
fell apart the manufacturers the
automakers they pulled out they now that
climate change is serious a number of
oil companies pulled out because they
too have changed their public position
on it
and so what you're left with now in the
united states is really a move an
anti-climate science movement that while
it's getting some support from the
fossil fuel industry and i'm not going
to name names but
there are a few that are still funding
them it's really driven much more by
free market ideology now than it is by
fossil fuel interest
and it's also gotten much more
widespread among people who are not
getting paid anything uh if you look at
the discussions about climate change in
the on the internet
uh you know most of those people are not
getting a salary they're not getting
money from anybody they're just trying
to express their views which are again
often rooted in a very deep um
free market ideology
so the issue has gotten much much more
complicated and that's much more
interesting last point
americans fundamentally don't trust
corporations
on this issue
when we ask people how much do you trust
them as a source of information they are
at the absolute bottom of the list so i
think the only way corporations can
actually be
uh powerful voices on this is when they
cut against stereotypes people expect
that corporations are going to be
anti-environmental they expect that
corporations are going to be
anti-climate change and when a company
comes out and says no
we think this is a serious problem and
we think we can be part of the solution
i think that that works in their favor
so
i actually do think corporations can
play a really important role in
communicating
all three of you mentioned deficiencies
in media coverage in your countries and
also tony you talked about the
importance of media in terms of you know
getting people to be concerned to be
aware
how what
what how do you explain the real
discrepancy between what we see in terms
of awareness in china versus the u.s i
mean is there a real difference in how
the media coverage covers
climate change in china do they draw the
connections between extreme weather
events
and impacts with the issue of climate
change what are the differences there
first of all i think that's a great
question and it's a great research
question so if you want a job come and
see me
but we don't i mean i think we don't
fully know the answer to that yet
because we haven't done the media
analysis across all three countries but
then i think you probably could say
something about how the chinese media
has been talking about climate change
i think uh chinese media uh there are
two um
uh categories
um for the actually uh chinese media uh
when they began to follow up climate
change issue is from copenhagen
so this is why i think copenhagen really
cannot just simply be named as a failure
and
they began to talk about climate change
since copenhagen and follow up the
negotiation from a very you know use
some technical terms but this kind of
news is not so
welcomed by chinese public this because
it's uh
too technical and it's a bit difficult
for
the
general public to understand
so now and
we are also provide we are providing uh
training for the chinese media and
we are discussing how to you know
provide some baby stories
and we take them
to the rural area and
we just arranged some
interview
for for the media and ask them you know
to provide them some chances to
interview the hulu witness and thus they
can
write
some better stories
and also
we will follow up the policy of course
we will
write some analysis write some comments
to the latest policy and also uh
inviting the
experts to make some analysis
but i think yes it's uh in fact
the media
coverage and it's uh
just as the
government is
the chinese government is doing they are
they are all at the very very beginning
on climate change
so this is why i think we can
as a center of climate change
communication we can contribute in this
fields
and i'll just add two other quick
comments i mean there are some important
other differences between the two
countries
first of all as i mentioned before the
united states has an active
disinformation movement
that has been very active in the us
media and so that has had i think a
significant impact on public opinion you
do not see a parallel disinformation
movement in china or in india or frankly
anywhere else in the world other than
canada the united united states
australia and the united kingdom
interestingly all english-speaking
countries um
um not to say that you won't find an
occasional skeptic somewhere but by and
large that is not a common discourse
in other countries or other media
the other big difference i think between
the u.s and china and you know in the
sense that the us has been talking about
climate change for a lot longer as part
of public discourse and as binman says
it's much newer of a topic in china so
there's a lot more to be done however
there's also a major difference in the
media between the two countries china's
media is much more concentrated and
consolidated
with you know much of the country
watching
chinese national television whereas we
lost that world when walter cronkite
stopped reporting in the united states i
mean that was decades ago the american
media is so fragmented now where
americans don't share a single media
universe anymore we all have our own
media sources that generally that many
people increasingly build around
themselves of a hall of self-reflecting
mirrors you know you can choose the
media source that gives you the opinions
and the viewpoints that you already
agree with as opposed to hearing a
viewpoint that's different than your own
so the u.s media landscape is much much
more complicated i think than what you
see in china at least currently but
that's changing that's changing to china
too okay
my name is
i'm from jordan representing german
environmental society ngo
well as we have introduced a very nice
academic exercise
and it looks like a debate between china
and the states
as ngos we do not care much about
what you are debating
in the communication or any other issues
as ngos we have a message we have
questions to be addressed to you first
of all i hope that i'm addressing the
right people
our worries
are you admitting that your countries
are the most polluting countries on this
earth
the other thing
are your countries going to sign
the charters the protocols concerning
the
global
war climate change
are you going to meet your
responsibilities
in front of those
victims or countries that cannot
meet the emergencies as in the states as
you just mentioned
and
the time has come really to see
that
the polluter
or political base
issue be implemented and everyone has to
stand
courageously
against our
indian
media responsibilities this is our
worries as
ngos
our words our people we
do care about your nice academic
exercise and
whatever information you have
submitted but at the same time we'd like
to see something on the ground to meet
really how to mitigate how to start how
to
deal with the climate change issues we
know that the states maybe they care
about baseball and football and other
other very long hobbies but in the rest
of the world they are worried about
their food about their health about
whatever issues you just mentioned and
this is my message as ngos and thank you
for the information you just introduced
and i'm academician as you are a
professor at the university of jordan
and i'd like to see that we are also as
say educated people to meet our
responsibilities and not to go with this
dream of just giving information without
action thank you
thank you very much i mean you're
raising really important fundamental
issues that obviously are a key part of
the negotiations here
in doha
in regards to at least the american
public i don't think we know enough
about the indian public or the chinese
public
again most people are incredibly local
local in their entire world view
um
i think most americans actually have
very limited understanding of
the way the rest of the world is
or
lives or uh these broader
responsibilities so uh as an example we
don't see that americans fully
understand
their unique historic role in greenhouse
gas emissions uh over time
so these discussions that are so central
to the negotiations here about who has
historic responsibility for the current
amount of greenhouse gases income in the
atmosphere
they don't understand that um
you know they don't understand the
concept of per capita emissions
okay yes yes you're absolutely right the
policymakers i think
well let me even say that
um
certain policymakers do understand there
are also many policymakers within the
united states government who do not
understand they simply do not and this
is why the us congress is not willing to
ratify the treaty this is why it was
never put forward by kyoto protocol was
never put forward by the clinton
administration because they knew they
could not get it passed by the u.s
senate so there are actually many policy
makers within the united states who do
not understand uh some of these key
factors uh moreover
the united states is fundamentally a
democracy and so there the leaders are
constrained
or enabled by what their people believe
and demand of them and that's one of the
main reasons why we think that public
opinion actually matters
beyond the fact that the public in its
choices as consumers as users of energy
and all of their other climate energy
related behaviors also has to play an
important role but in the end you're
absolutely right this is an issue that
has to be taken up by policy makers the
question is how do we get policy makers
to take this issue seriously that's the
real challenge
one of the ways that we get there is
through the public it's not the only way
there are many other pressures on
policymakers but one of the important
ways at least in a democracy is to
engage the public to demand action
thank you thank you to all the panel for
the presentation i think it's been
really informative my name is ray wills
i'm an adjunct professor at the
university of western australia and also
from perth in australia and also
the former ceo of the sustainability
association of australia which is an
industry chamber where businesses are
responding so very interested in the
words
rupert murdoch's news limited news corp
uh have clearly played a huge role in
the media right across the world uh
rupert of course is from australia and
one of his ceos in australia is is
famous for saying that news gets in the
way of good advertising
and the challenge in that context is
that we also know
that right-wing
commentary
publications get more revenue
than left-wing publication
commentary and so there is a tendency
particularly in australia but no doubt
also in the us uh for that commentary to
be more extreme and we know that when it
is more extreme they see more
advertising revenue so that's a critical
challenge in the context of
how this message gets out there but i
really i've got lots of questions but
i'm going to go down to two the first
one really is in relation to the us
one view of the data might be that
the absence of media reporting has
improved public understanding
and i guess the the second part of the
question is in fact for china and
there's been some commentary to that
already and that is uh is there any
negative reporting of climate change in
the chinese press do we understand this
and i think one of the things that
differs between particularly china and
the usa of course has the climate change
models tell us and as the experience
shows us is that china is far more
exposed as is australia to climate
change than the us is the actual
outcomes for climate change in the us
climatically are
relatively modest compared to china and
australia
and africa india and in fact the us in
the climate change models uh don't do
quite so bad uh everybody does bad but
not quite so much so i actually wonder
how much of that climate impact that's
really experienced in china already
has been important and the fact that
this appears to be no negative reporting
in china of the skeptic
reporting the skeptics in china thank
you
um
great couple comments thank you very
much um
i'm not going to comment much on the
idea that extreme views leads to more
money um but i do think you're raising
the critical point that the media
is a business
in most places it's a business and so
they will make decisions about what to
report based on
their assessment of will this bring
eyeballs or not um that's one of the
reasons why we are trying to find other
kinds of communication channels and
simply the news media the news media
will play an important role but we
believe for instance weathercasters is
another important communication channel
but it's not that alone we need to be
engaging communicators across society
companies
faith community
health professionals uh the military um
i mean there are
all of us in the end in a society are
communicators including with our own
friends and family and all of them need
to be engaged in having a national and
even international conversation about
this issue um
about the question of has the absence of
media reporting actually improve public
understanding that's a really funny
comment um
and i'll just say this is that when it
comes to the extreme weather story okay
for a long time scientists have had a
basic talking point and you all know
this talking point you can never say
that any one extreme weather event was
caused by climate change right that is
the standard scientific qualifying
answer to this question whenever an
extreme weather event happens they say
well you can never say this was caused
by climate change
so they always refused to talk about it
likewise the media
wouldn't talk about it either i don't
know how many stories i saw in 2011
about the latest extreme weather event
and someone would say so does this have
anything to do with broader trends and
nobody would answer the question so the
media wasn't really talking about it and
yet we found in our data that americans
themselves were starting to connect the
dots okay and the point there is really
important and that is that
people are not empty vessels being
waiting to be told what to think by the
media or politicians or anyone else they
are actively making meaning out of their
own experience
and the fact is that when people see
there's an old saying if you see
something once it happens it happens
twice it's coincidence if it happens
three times you're beginning to see a
pattern what happens four times five
times six times seven times eight times
uh and in the united states it has been
over 20 times of just record settings
new events
people themselves start connecting the
dots they are actively trying to
interpret this new reality and
themselves are saying maybe this has
something to do with climate change so
in that case i think the media
and scientists and everybody else can do
a really important role in helping
people
solidify those connections to understand
when they actually make sense
we do know there's a
relationship between climate change and
say extreme representing temperatures
and also where it doesn't make sense you
can't say that it's true that climate
change is causing tornadoes there's just
no science that shows the direct link
there so
the main thing is that these are
teachable moments they're one of the few
times in american media landscape when
americans are actually paying attention
to an issue extreme weather that is
closely related to climate change and
not thinking about the latest celebrity
or the latest scandal or what's going on
in the government or all the other
topics that we focus on
uh sex fair question about china and
actually chinese government uh
conducting a national report additional
strategy report on adapting
adaptation climate change adaptation yes
and
there are many uh national survey
conducted in the past two years and here
i have two group of
data to provide and the first one is in
china poverty-stricken areas have a
strong
correlation to
ecologically 3gl areas and their
geographical distribution is equally
very similar
this below is a data in
1997 and
74 percent of those living in
sensitive ecological areas are in
uh in power impoverished countries uh
counties accounting for roughly
81 percent of the total population in uh
impoverished counties and according to
uh
statistics from the ministry of
environmental protection this is another
data
in 2007.
59 of the people living in the
absolute poverty
living in
ecological damaged areas
in the interior of the country so the
percentage of the people living in the
poverty affected by climate change is
expected to grow and here i have another
data as just from the
latest white category before doha
the first one the first paragraph of the
forward is in
2011 alone natural disaster affected
430 million people and caused directly
direct economic loss losses of
309.6 billion
i can give you a link the linkage of
this report if you want
i mean i
was sure that why you feel that india is
less exposed to climate change because
when we look at the impact we look at
the three-dimensional exposure
sensitivity and adaptive capacity and uh
some of the indian cities mumbai
chennai are all you know have high
density of population living in the
seashore which is you know highly
vulnerable to sea level rise and also
just like china
you know majority of people are still
under the poverty line or just some
sitting right above it so any kind of
extreme weather event is going to highly
impact their uh ability to access food
and this is again india is a highly
agriculture based economy where more
than 50 percent of the population is
still uh involved in agriculture which
is again practiced with traditional
troops not recognized so any kind of
change in for example the rainfall
patterns or increasing uh an intensity
or severity of extreme relevance is
highly vulnerable and go to push the
population to even down uh the kind of
development that india has seen over the
last 20 years after india you know
opened this economy that is under threat
because of climate change so the whole
the development that we have seen for
two decades is on the threat because of
climate change and might push the people
to adjust about poverty line back into
it
question
steve sawyer from global wind energy
council um
just want to get your reaction to a
string of observations
um
you've said that the global climate
coalition has gone away
i would say that it's come back
not in the same form
but if you look at the amount of money
that was spent to basically
get the republican party to adopt the
previous positions of the global
climate coalition in the last election
it's extraordinary
and you know you say the u.s is a
democracy well technically speaking it's
a republic and there's a fundamental
difference it is possible to elect the
president without him getting the
majority of votes as has happened
several times in the history but i would
go a bit further and say that it's
bordering on the edge of plutocracy
especially with these supreme court
systems which allows
the
fossil fuel industry to put unlimited
money basically into
the outcome of the election mostly
through buying the media
then you get to the point where the very
interesting list of countries that use
history of the world
get out of direct politics in order for
this sort of sanity to prevail
a great set of observations and
questions um you're absolutely right
they still have a fair amount of power
and certain interests within the united
states uh have and i think in particular
it's no shock to you certainly or groups
like the koch brothers which is an
interesting combination not only of
you know incredible fossil fuel
self-interest they are
mostly from the fossil fuel industry
but they are also
hardcore free market uh individualistic
worldview libertarian type ideology and
it's the fusion of those in those
owners private owners of that particular
company and they have been tremendous
funders of a lot of this disinformation
campaign so uh yeah absolutely they
haven't disappeared by any means
i think what you're raising though are
fundamental questions that the united
states is struggling with right now
about its democracy
and
you know
it's all throughout the system um
you know it's the way we make decisions
in the senate the fact that you need 60
votes to pass anything now
because of the filibuster rule
these are tiny bureaucratic
rules and they have an enormous impact
on the american government's ability or
actually dis
inability to actually take action on a
whole host of issues climate change just
being one of them
so i mean i think i have to say as an
observer of american politics american
politics is pretty dysfunctional
across the board right now
and i think the current discussions in
washington over the fiscal cliff is just
more evidence of their inability to
actually work together to solve common
problems
again climate change just adds you add
that one to a very long list of problems
the united states hasn't been able to
deal with and we've got some big
structural issues like the way that
money is able to influence political
speech in our country so
yes we've got things to work on
so
maybe we'll take two more questions
but for lunch
thanks um i'm i'm jonathan then i'm the
head of communications at the ipcc and
i've got a couple of questions and
observations more in a personal than an
additional capacity otherwise i'll get
shot
so um
coming back to this topic of the the
impact of extreme events in the united
states on people's awareness of climate
change i've heard it i've heard it
certainly often that when weather
classes talk about them typically they
don't make the links with climate change
the events are treated in the
it would be very interesting to see how
public awareness in china and climate
change develops but with personal
exposure to extreme events around the
general awareness
you you
mentioned tony in your
similarly in the chinese
survey we see that 89
of chinese people say the government
should pay attention to the issue 68
the government has the most important
is the most important actor in this so
again it will be interesting to see
whether that public pressure has any
impact or any effect on the stance of
chinese negotiators and these sorts of
negotiations
and
we talked about what we talked about
below the low understanding in the media
of climate change in china and india in
the united states and i think um it's
very important
um
been mentioned this is very important to
have some kind of um
training for media inclination
science-based training so work workshops
we're even talking about doing something
like that um in the united states um for
uh journalists who are based at the
united nations there um so the ipcc and
the un are looking at doing something
there as you know the the unfccc
organizes workshops for
for journalists and developing countries
i think you'll be well worth looking at
our ways of doing that so i mean in
china and india and
other countries too and
that's why i'm really speaking past me
now now um
those sort of workshops should look at
the
stance of the
national policy of national negotiations
um but they won't always both always
overlap 100 percent with a general
understanding of climate change and um
then um
tony you and jackie should talk about
the need for simple clear
messages and um the ipcc puts out these
massive reports um we do produce
summer's policy makers which are 15 18
20 pages long even they are pretty
hard for the non-specialists to make
sense of and
i know that a lot of people and ngos and
others produce what we call derivative
products so they use translations and um
thought of a better word idiots guides
in the ipcc report and it'll be very
interesting to see what could be done
in
china and india on that in china there's
the additional dimension of
translation as well but it would be
interesting to explore
that although the ipcc
can't get uh can't give its
stamp of approval on something like that
it can certainly help informally with
with uh making sure that those
derivative products
are accurate
so thank you very much
uh great thank you jonathan uh great
points so let me pick up on a couple of
them um first of all uh to your first
point about weather captures most do not
talk about climate change right now most
do not but we've actually surveyed that
community twice and we know that
uh about 20 of them uh would like to do
so they say i believe it's happening i
think it's human cause i think it's my
responsibility as part of my job to help
my viewers understand this issue because
it's going to directly impact
but they say they don't because they
lack the training
they lack the materials they don't have
the pictures the graphics the animations
the scripts that they can immediately go
on on air
and deliver and they say if you help me
if you support me with that
i'll start talking about climate change
tomorrow i mean being a little
exaggerating but you get the idea so
we've actually developed a national
network of institutions including nasa
and noaa and
their own associations
american meteorological society the
national weather association the
broadcast meteorologist themselves to
come together to support broadcast
meteorologists as communicators so to
support those that are already ready to
do it and then secondly to train those
that are still trying to make up their
mind they're still not sure because this
isn't their field either they're not
experts in climate science so
we've been holding workshops all across
the country where we sit them down with
some of the world's leading climate
scientists to answer their questions
what is the difference between a climate
model and a weather model you know how
can you be so sure that you know that
it's human caused and not caused by the
sun or whatever and so we've already
developed models and are beginning to
scale that up across the country
so there's there's uh very active work
taking place there um internationally uh
climate communication day is being
sponsored by uh i think is the internews
organization
that works internationally and they are
doing media trainings for journalists uh
around the world to get and bringing
them to these international conferences
so i think that's at least a start
towards what ultimately needs to be done
last point is your
thing on public support for
international treaties
and you used a word that i think is
actually
i'm going to change it and should say
why i think it's important i think what
we see there is that the american public
has support or
has given their permission
for an international treatment
but that is not the same thing as
pressure
for an international treaty and that's
the fundamental difference americans
in general has basically told their
political leaders yes we want you to do
things that are going to help
investing in clean energy you know
ending fossil fuel subsidies regulating
carbon dioxide is a blue passing an
international treaty they support all of
that but what they're not doing is
demanding that they change there right
now is no organized mobilized
powerful political force in the united
states akin to the civil rights movement
or the women's movement or the uh
any other social movements you want to
name that's out there actually demanding
that uh politicians that i think that's
one of the missing ingredients at least
in the united states
my great feedback to
jonathan's
advice i think most of your
most of your comments are
good advice for our center and the first
feedback is
about the further survey we are planning
to do the segment survey within your
university in the coming weeks and we
also will do the further survey of the
specific
perspective in the coming
months so
of course if we can get ipcc get a
job help that will be wonderful
so the second feedback is
uh
yes you mentioned whether
the government have fueled the public
pressure yes i think so because we uh we
just
shared
our survey report with trans government
before they release this white paper
it's just a few days before the release
releases one but one way when we read
this one we found they have our
suggestions have been included in this
white paper so this is uh
this is
why i think yes
it's a good evaluation for our work and
i think the government have field
they need to
feel they need to do more to learn
the public's voice especially in climate
change
area
and the third one is about the training
and you give us a good suggestion that
we can do the
further training about um
to the media and especially with uh
some experts from ips such as ipcc and
other specific
institutes health and support of course
i think just like the
crop 18's slogan can't be i think not
come to me just but continue count all
of you in
well i don't think we can actually do
better than that so i know it's time for
lunch we're going to be here and we
encourage you all to come ask us
questions and also to
talk with each other so thank you all
for again coming on a sunday morning and
we look forward to continuing the
conversation thank you
you